The incredible Alex Livinalli.
[MUSIC] It's
wonderful to see you.
Exciting, right?
I mean, she was kind of
she was kind of fangirling
out over you, too.
We got to say that, right?
OK, say we're here to your
Marvel fans, because they're--
We are here!
[LAUGHING]
Straight from Ta'lo
and we have Attuma.
What is it like to be a
part of the Marvel universe?
- Yeah.
- My God.
Unreal.
Yeah.
This is so unreal,
just being here.
Finally getting here from
production to everything.
And now, oh my God.
Pinch me, pinch me,
please pinch me.
[SHOUTS]
You're breathing.
You're awake.
We know you
can't tell us much,
but what can you tell
us about your character?
Such a special project.
We all work so hard.
And making a movie of this
magnitude, it's no simple joke.
Not at all.
You add everything that's
going on in the world.
The pandemic, it's
even more difficult.
I am very proud that
we all came together
and we worked so
hard to make this.
And I'm excited for
the fans to go see it,
and then you guys are
going to love this
because we work so hard for it.
[LAUGHING]
OK, you talked about
the process of production.
But what was it like getting
the call that you are now
a part of the Marvel universe?
It was like, I got the
call and I was like--
[LAUGHING]
Yeah, that's it.
That's about all I would do.
What?
And then I hung up.
And then I call my mom.
Straight to voicemail.
I call my girlfriend.
She didn't answer.
Oh no.
Then I call my mom, and
she finally answered.
I told her.
And then we were all
excited, and we're here.
She's somewhere around here.
And this isn't just any role.
I mean, you are a
general of Namor's army.
I can't say that.
I am Attuma.
Yes.
And I am so, so, so excited that
he's finally here in the MCU
and people are going
to meet Attuma.
Attuma.
And should we be
afraid of Attuma?
Listen, he's a very
humble, loving person.
He loves his people, but
he's someone you don't
want to mess with or piss off.
Yeah, because he'll tax you.
Uh-oh.
Big time.
More than the IRS.
I already have real fears.
I don't need that in my
movies too, my friend.
Does the hair make an
underwater appearance,
you know?
Of course, I want
to make this clear.
Attuma's hair is real.
You heard it
here first, folks.
You heard it here first.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with us.
We can't wait to
watch your hair.
Thank you so much, guys.
Absolutely.
Lovely to speak with you.
(CROSSTALK) Look
forward to seeing you.